وما في استديو ازميل خالد الغراب اهلا بك
خالد لا تتحدث عن هذه الحكومه ونحن الان
في انتظار الاعلان عن التشكيله النهائيه
لماذا تثير اولا كثير من المخاوف لدى
الفلسطينيين
حكومه يمنيه متشدده يعني المزيد من العنف
المزيد من عمليات الاقتحام عمليه القتل اا
ربما تدمير المنازل الابعاد همم كل هذا
همم بالنسبه للفلسطينيين خبر سيء لكن في
النهايه جرعه زائده من عنف هو موجود
بالاصل صحيح يمثل خطوره لكن هناك ما هو
اخطر الاخطر هو ما يغير مستقبل واقع الارض
المحتله هذا ربما سيكون اكثر خطوره على
فلسطينيه وهناك اسباب تعهم الى القلق بهذا
شان يعني ما تسرب حتى الان في الاتفاقيات
التي تمت بينها الاحزاب المتحالفه معه همم
انه سيتم الاعتراف
السلطانيه موجوده في داخل فالغربيه لم
يعرف العدد بالضبط لكن مجرد الاعتراف بؤر
اقيمت على ارض محتله بحسب القانون الدولي
هذا معناه انه سيتم اعطاء شرعيه اسرائيليه
لا اقول شرعيه دوليه شرعيه اسرائيليه لبؤر
السيطانيه هي غير شرعيه بالاساس هذا سيصعب
على اي حكومه اسرائيليه انرغبت ربما تحت
ضغوط دوليه ان تحاول ازاله هذه البؤر لن
تتمكن من منحه الشرعيه الان اعطاء شرعيه
للاستطانيه يعني ان يسمح لها بمد الكهرباء
والخدمات همم هذه البوها ستتحول الى
مستوطنات حقيقيه وتعني الاستيلاء على
المزيد من الارض المحتله داخل الضيف
العربيه وبالتالي ان ذهبت الارض لن يبقى
ارض لما يمكن ان يقام لاحقا ما يتمنى في
فلسطينيه يونيون الدوله الصينيه لان
الصراحه هو كله على الارض في نهايه الامر
لكن هناك ايضا ما هو اكثر من ذلك ما تم
تسريبه حتى الان ماذا يقول انه همم سيتم
نقل السلطه لحياه الاسرائيليين في المنطقه
جيم من الاداره المدنيه الى الوزارات
المختصه داخل اسرائيل اعلى من كلامه عيد
مفهوم ساضع
المنطقه جيم في الضفه الغربيه همم هي نحو
تمثل نحو 60% من الاراضي الضفه الغربيه
وهي اكثر المناطق اهميه من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه وثراء من ناحيه طبيعه التربه
وتوفر المياه فيها
هناك العديد من البؤر السلطانيه الموجوده
في هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه هي اراضي
مختلفه
وقرات دوليه تطالب اسرائيل بالخروج منها
ولانها اراد محتله لم تكن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تديرها من همم الوزارات
المختصه داخل اسرائيل كما تدير امور في تل
ابيب على سبيل المثال وانما خلقت ما يسمى
اداره مدنيه لاداره شؤون هذه المنطقه اذا
هي تحت السيطره امنيه للجيش الاسرائيلي
وتحت اداره لتسمى الاداره المدنيه الان
عندما تنقل من تحت الاداره المدنيه من يد
الاداره المدنيه الى داخل الوزارات ده في
داخل دوله اسرائيل هذا معناه اعتبار هذه
المناطق هي جزء من الاراضي الاسرائيليه
وتضارب مباشره من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
يعني عمليه ضم بشكل فعلي بدون ان يعلم
اسرائيل بالضبط وبالتالي يعطي فرد واقع
جديد وهذا طبعا هي محاوله لتغيير واقع همم
الموجود على الارض ان هذه الارض عم 76
وعلى القرارات الدوليه تطالب اسرائيل
طيب خالد داخليا هناك ايضا في السماعاتنا
الى بعض الاراء لماذا ينظر الاسرائيليون
اليوم الى هذه الحكومه او الحكومه المقبله
بالكثير من الخوف والريبه وربما هناك
مخاطر على الداخل الاسرائيلي من هذه
الحكومه لماذا لان تهدد الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل طبعا
نقاش بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع بالنسبه
لاسرائيل اي ديموقراطيه فيها فئه في
العالم تقوم على ماذا على مبدا فصل
السلطات يعني هناك سلطه حره تختار من
الشعب لتقوم بالتشريع بشكل مستقل سلطه
التنفيذيه تنفذ القوانين تراقب من اعلام
حر يفترض ان يكون حر وقضاء يعاقب ان تمت
مخالفات ما يحدث الان من اعداد مشروعات
قوانين سيحاول الاحزاب التي تشترك مع
زانيها في الحكم ان تفرضها او تصوت عليها
وهم لهم الاغلبيه الان في الكنيسه يضرب
هذه المفاهيم استقلاليه القضاء هناك ستكون
هناك محاوله من خلال سن قوانين تجعل
الكنيست يطعن في قرارات وينقض قرارات
المحكمه العليا يعني السلطه التشريعيه
ستتحكم في قرارات
القضاء وبالتالي يكون هناك شك في ان يكون
هناك عداله في هذه المجتمع الان من جابر
ماذا يريد
اا من اقول لهذه يريد ان يكون هو من يحدد
السياسه العامه للشرطه وليس مفوض الشرطه
طبعا هذا ايضا امر في غايه الخطوره المفوض
الشرطه هو موظف يطبق القانون بدون اي
خلفيه سياسيه لكن عندما ياتي وزير بخلفيه
سياسيه ويقول انا من يحدد السياسه العامه
بدون ان نفهم ما هي هذه السياسه العامه
هذا معناه انه سينفذ ما يريده هو سيادته
وليس بالضروره ما يقول والقانون وبالتالي
سيتم تاسيس جهاز تنفيذي يفترض انه يعمل
بشكل مستقل وفقا اا القانون بالاضافه لان
هناك حديث عن مشاريع قوانين اخرى توفر
حمايه
الملاحق قضائيا وهذا ما انا انا السياسه
تتدخل في عمل القضاء مره اخرى كل هذا طبعا
يؤدي الى خلط المفاهيم وبالتالي لا يكون
هناك مبدا الفصل بين سلطات بشكل واضح همم
في الغالب سيؤثر ذلك ايضا على حريه
الاعلام التي هي بالاساس تعمل تحت الرقابه
العسكريه اسرائيليه كل هدف النهايه سيهدد
بشكل قوي حتى كما حتى قالت المذيع العام
الاسرائيليه قد يجعل من الديمقراطيه في
الصليل الكليبه وليس فعل شكرا جزيلا لك
خالد الغراب لي